[Musique]
le duel à distance entre marine le pen
et eric zemmour les deux candidats à la
présidence et larmes en éthique ce même
jour l'un à lille l'autre à rance
fait rage marquée par des défections
dans le camp du rassemblement national
au profit du leader de reconquête on en
parle avec nos invités dès le début de
ce journal
[Musique]
ce campagne présidentielle au cours de
laquelle les chez les jaunes compte bien
se faire entendre ils ont manifesté
aujourd'hui leurs revendications sont
multiples baisse des taxes cros
valorisation salariale suppression aussi
du balzac final compte rendu de cette
mobilisation dans un instant
[Musique]
après les états unis et la france
apporte son soutien militaire aux
émirats arabes unis paris va aider abou
dhabi chez à sécuriser son espace aérien
il est la cible des attaques des
rebelles yéménites outils proche de
l'iran arrive à nous envoyer
des avions de combat rafale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
un dernier sondage ipsos pour le
parisien les donne à égalité marine le
pen hir eczéma ou autour de 14% des
intentions de vote derrière la candidate
à l'est républicain valérie pécresse à
plus de 16% emmanuel macron 24% les
candidats de la droite nationaliste en
meeting ce même jour marine le pen à la
tribune en ce moment même à rans eric
zemmour ces luttes adressé à ses
militants dans l'après midi à lille le
leader de reconquête dont la venue dans
le nord n'était pas du goût de tous cet
après midi sur place notre reporter
d'aller de khalifa
zemmour dégage lille contre zemmour les
slogans hostiles n'ont pas manqué contre
le chef de file de reconquête eric
zemmour lors de cette manifestation
organisée par plusieurs organisations
anti el fasciste il était à des
centaines à défiler dans les rues de
lille afin de dénoncer le discours
haineux et racistes d'eric zemmour ans
selon leurs mots plusieurs tensions eu
lieu lors de cette manifestation des
affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre des jets de
projectiles ont lieu ce à quoi ils ont
répondu par des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes
lors de cette manifestation mais toutes
ces tensions se sont vite dispatchés
dans l'ensemble la mobilisation est là
elle n'a pas connu de grande violence
l'objectif était de se faire entendre
par tous les moyens écoutez le
porte-parole de jeune garde anti
fascistes de lille nous on a décidé de
re la pas être organisateur de ce
rassemblement parce que voilà cessé d
organisation beaucoup plus
institutionnels etc avec lesquels on
peut travailler occasionnellement mais
ce n'est pas notre mode d'action des
organisations de jeunesse on essaye
voilà de faire des cortèges dynamique
notamment dans les manifestations etc
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle à la
manifestation de l'après midi par contre
il était important de montrer notre tête
aussi pour dire que voilà il ya des
liens de solidarité qui doivent se faire
s'ils ont toujours existé à gauche face
à l'extrême droite il était bon de
rappeler que ouais l'ennemi il est bien
trop grand pour pour rester chacun dans
notre coin une mobilisation dans le
sillage du rassemblement qui a eu lieu
ce matin ici même place de la république
à l'initiative de tine aubry la maire
socialiste de lille et du président de
sos racisme a dénoncé le racisme mais
aussi la montée de l'extrême droite à
travers la france montrait qu'eric
zemmour ne fait pas partie de l'adn de
la ville c'était l'objectif principal
est des nombreux rassemblements
organisés dans la métropole écouter
plusieurs des manifestants cette ville
c'est une ville qui est dans le pays des
droits de l'homme une ville où a été
chanté pour la première fois
l'international un champ de solidarité
et donc tout le contraire de la haine
d'un candidat qui ne milite que pour
pour le contre plutôt contre
l'immigration contre les étrangers c'est
pas un candidat qui
[Musique]
qui a des valeurs qui a un programme à
réel programme crois qu'on vit une
époque et un petit peu compliqué en
france avec beaucoup de fractures dans
nos sociétés on est en plus dans un
moment où la pandémie
mais une forte tension sur sur tout le
monde je crois que il faut aussi savoir
passer des messages de paix d'apaisement
et puis l'ouverture sur le monde je
crois que la france c'est pas à la
france de monsieur zemmour la france
aujourd'hui c'est une france
multiculturelle ouverte est qui et qui
sait accueillir correctement tout le
monde un dispositif de sécurité
conséquent été mis en place dans la
ville de lille pour éviter tout
affrontement entre militants un d'eric
zemmour et partisan anti fasciste c'est
est elle plus l'objectif aujourd'hui
pour éviter de nouvelles scènes de
violence qu'on l'a vue à villepinte lors
du deuxième meeting de campagne d'eric
zemmour
et on revient sur ces deux grands
meetings du jour avec philippe pascot
fric rives un ex-conseiller municipal de
manuel valls à evry et gilles à casanova
spécialiste en communication
bonsoir messieurs crient merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france gilles
casanova aujourd'hui cet eric zemmour
qui suscite l'ire de ces manifestants
d'hier antifa
vous savez pier paolo pasolini a
expliqué que la prochaine vague fasciste
portera le nom anti fasciste parce que
au fond cette idée d'interdire la parole
d'interdire un propos c'est une idée qui
n'est pas démocratie lorsque la gauche a
quelque chose à dire elle dit quelque
chose est en général l'extrême droite
n'a pas beaucoup de toi ou deux prises
entre 1947 et
1983 l'extrême droite a représenté entre
deux et trois et demi pour cent des voix
lorsque la gauche partir du tournant de
84 a du mal à tenir un discours de
gauche rausch qui répondent aux attentes
des populations qu'elle est censée
représenter alors vous avez un retour de
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui 60 70 % des
ouvriers et des employés ont voté ou
votent tous s'apprêtent à voter pour des
partis qui sont considérés comme à
l'extrême droite ce n'est pas en faisant
des manifestations de rue que la gauche
peut avancer ce quelque chose en positif
c'est en ayant un programme en ayant une
proposition on renouant avec sa capacité
à représenter les catégories populaires
philippe pascot eric zemmour taxe est
aujourd'hui par ses militants
anti-fascistes taxé de 10 kg et l'asile
à m il ya quelques temps pas si loin que
ça c'était marine le pen qui se
retrouvaient objet de ces critiques
comment est-ce que vous quel regard est
ce que vous portez sur ce qui ressemble
à une évolution
évolution survie j'appelle ça plutôt une
régression maintenant moi je suis pas
inquiet je compare zemmour et marine le
pen que je connais bien 1 deux fusées
macro nien il arrange macron la
différence qu'il ya entre les deux c'est
que la fusée moore comme les autres
avait explosé en plein vol et la fusée
marine le pen comme d'habitude elle
n'arrivera jamais à décoller je suis
d'accord est ce que disait mon
prédécesseur la gauche aujourd'hui qui
malheureusement n'arrive pas à trouver
un discours cohérent
se rabat en gueulant après les extrêmes
et leur donne plus de voix autre chose
mais moi je suis pas inquiet zemmour il
va exploser gentiment plein vol parce
que de toute manière ce qu'il raconte
lui marine le pen c'est tellement creux
que ça peut pas aller loin c'est une
bulle donc la bulle est en train de
gonfler il ya des gens qui souffle
dedans les gens désabusés les gens qui
ont eu marre de la gauche les gens qu'on
ait eu marre de la droite les gens qui
savent plus vers qui se tourner
aujourd'hui il ya un homme neuf qu'ils
ont l'impression qu'il est neuf il
appelle zemmour donc on va le voir mais
vous savez les gens sont très volatiles
très très volatile aujourd'hui sont pour
l'extrême droite parce que il ya les
médias qui sont derrière il ya les
médias qui pousse quand vous voyez la
façon dont zemmour est poussé dans tous
les médias officiels
c'est normal que les gens qui ne
regardent que bfm ou hanouna
suivent monsieur zemmour mais je vous
dis ça va être une grosse fusée qui va
exploser en plein vol et zemmour il va
se réduire comme un paquet de cacahuètes
flétri et marine le pen comme d'habitude
ne décollera pas mais les seules
personnes que ça arrange ces deux
phénomènes de foire je dis bien ces deux
phénomènes de foire c'est monsieur
macron qui en ce moment est en train de
se lécher les babines parce qu'on parle
pas de lui on parle pas de son programme
on parle pas de sa non candidature vous
vous rendez compte qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un type qui n'est pas candidat qui se
sert de la présidence et qui a déjà ses
signatures il ya quand même un malaise
et ça personne n'en parle parce qu'on
est tellement occupée par le phénomène
zemmour est et lepéniste qu'on fait pas
attention au reste moi j'y fais même pas
grave zemmour ces deux-là de la roupie
de sansonnet pour moi on a du mal à
croire à une coïncidence à angers le
casanova c'est deux candidats de la
droite nationaliste qui tiennent meeting
le même jour qui veut faire passer un
message à l'autre quel message
la question c'est
la question c'est celui d'un vote
qui s'adresse la même
disons partie de l'électorat une partie
qui est déçue par la gauche et une
partie qui est déçu par la droite et là
on voit bien que on est d'un certain
point de vue un petit peu dans une
situation comparable aux rapports entre
georges marchais et françois mitterrand
il ya 50 ans françois mitterrand n'avait
rien il avait une petite formation qui
s'appelait la convention des
institutions républicaines et le parti
communiste v 25 % des voix et puis
françois mitterrand a surgi et l'a fait
de la politique il a conquis un parti
politique qu'il a renouvelés revitaliser
et il est passé devant les communistes
qui avaient pourtant les gros bataillons
l'idée d'eric zemmour c'est un petit peu
la même c'est à dire arriver à prendre à
marine le pen les gros bataillons de ce
vote le seul problème c'est que cela
s'est passé sur dix ans entre françois
mitterrand et
le parti communiste français alors que
là il voudrait que ça se passe en 10
semaines c'est beaucoup plus difficile
ce que l'on peut penser c'est que au
dernier moment les électeurs de ce parti
de l'électorat choisiront de faire un
vote utile c'est à dire que celui que
les sondages donneront en position
d'être véritablement au deuxième tour ou
en tout cas d'être vraiment en tête
attrapera les sondages de l'autre et on
ne peut pas penser qu'il y aura par les
sondages les votes par dont on ne peut
pas penser qu'il y aura deux
candidats qui seront au coude à coude
alors que leur programme n'est pas
véritablement distants si l'on voit
l'ensemble du champ politique qui est
présenté à cette présidentielle philippe
haas quand on entendait à l'instant j'ai
le casanova relire sur la gauche de
françois mitterrand à léo aujourd'hui
tout simplement la gauche en france
elle est dans ses baskets elle se
cherche il ya qu de gauche aujourd'hui
mais il ya plus de droite n'ont plus
aujourd'hui sophie quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui un type comme robert hue qui
soutient macron dire que le buffet qui
soutient qu'à buffet la présidente de
région qui soutient taubira les mecs qui
vont à droite les mecs qui vont en
bouche il ya plus de gauche je vous lis
il ya plus de droits non plus il ya des
gens qui se cherchent aujourd'hui il ya
un peuple qui cherche un leader il ya un
peuple et qui cherchent un renouveau il
ya un peuple qui est en train de se dire
on en a marre du mec qui nous a dirigé
pendant cinq ans via un type peut être
car il peut être que ça va être le
meilleur
y'a pas de gauche aujourd'hui et
honnêtement il n'y a pas de droite joli
quand vous y promener banham pécresse
c'est la même chose que macron quand
vous prenez les différentes gauches qui
sont en train de se présenter un chat
n'y retrouverait pas ses petits
aujourd'hui est le problème il est là
c'est que les gens ne savent pas donc
qu'ils se dirigent vers celui qui a
l'air le plus neuf le plus le plus haut
naître entre guillemets entre guillemets
parce que pour trouver de l'honnêteté
j'ai tous les candidats il faut vraiment
chercher très loin moi j'ai dit que la
chose la plus importante au jury a
retenu pour les électeurs c'est qu'il
faut changer la façon dont on veut qu
aujourd'hui on votait ont choisi c'est
au premier tour et on éliminer au
deuxième
aujourd'hui je pense que les gens il
faut qu'ils aient éliminé au premier
tour et on verra ce qui reste au
deuxième mais surtout éliminons au
premier tour pour revenir sur le duel à
eric zemmour marine le pen j'ai le
casanova comment est-ce que vous
analysez la communication aujourd'hui de
la chef de file du rassemblement
national face à eric zemmour roland
entendu suggéré ce samedi à son rival je
la cite de faire le ménage dans son
mouvement après l'avoir accusé de
communautarisme et d'attirer dans sa
campagne des catholiques
traditionalistes des pailles ans et
quelques nazis
pourquoi pourquoi cet homme qu'est ce
qu'elle cherche
alors où on est là dans un phénomène qui
semble plutôt de l'ordre du caractére
aux logiques voilà une dame de la
famille le pen qui a essayé de
dédiaboliser son image de dédiaboliser
l'image de sa famille et qui a dû être
obligé de rompre largement avec son père
et plus largement encore avec beaucoup
d'amis de son père qu'elle a dû écarter
de la direction et même du parti et puis
voilà que ces gens comme ils ont été
écartés par la famille le pen vont se
retrouver derrière eric zemmour et sa
basse à l'énervent parce que c'est elle
qui à l'image sulfureuse beaucoup plus
qu'eric zemmour qui est connu comme un
éditorialiste de télévision de radio de
presse écrite depuis de nombreuses
années et qui est beaucoup plus admis
par l'establishment que le nom le pen
alors on comprend très bien humainement
qu'elle quelques l on est gros sur la
patate dire et on en langage populaire
mais d'un autre côté son discours de
dire attention il ya des vrais nazis là
bas il faut faire barrage ça ressemble
aux discours des castors régulièrement
utilisé pour la faire perdre au second
tour donc elle joue contre elle même
philippe pascot l'arrivée d'eric zemmour
a évidemment bousculer le champ
politique il marche sur les
plates-bandes de marine le pen qui était
installé depuis de nombreuses années le
discours de marine le pen a évolué on en
parlait à l'instant avec un gilles
casanova elle revendique aujourd'hui une
certaine normalisation normalisation qui
a été décrié au sein du rm face à ce
discours beaucoup plus virulent d'eric
zemmour est ce qu elle le défend
clairement aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle
n'assume par stratégie cette
dédiabolisation face au leader de
reconquête ont de quoi ils se balancent
des petits cailloux à la figure on est
dans une cour de récréation des nazis y
en a dans deux côtés y en a chez zemmour
il y en a chez ayant lâché marine le pen
ça veut rien dire encore une fois il
centra d'amuser la galerie et pendant
qu'ils amusent la galerie et ben les
gens ne regardent pas ce qui se passe
ailleurs l'ensemble de la médiatisation
aujourd'hui de l'élection présidentielle
se passe entre les petites phrase de
zemmour et les petites phrases de marine
le pen
mais ces gains grand n'importe quoi mais
bon ça marche donc qui continue et les
désabusés les gens qui savent vraiment
pas vers qui se tourner et ben écoute
ses discours lénifiants et qui prend qui
prône des gros pratique vous rendez
compte on parle de nazis pour la
présidentielle mais on parle pas des
maisons de retraite on parle pas du club
du travail on parle pas de futur on
parle pas de l'environnement on parle de
rien c'est ça une présidentielle pas
pour moi mais je vous dis encore une
fois zemmour macron 10 arrange le
président en place il arrange les mac
rogne pendant ce temps là monsieur
macron sur son petit fauteuil de non
candidats se lèchent les babines il faut
que les gens se rendre compte que le le
vrai enjeu il n'est pas entre zemmour et
marine le pen de toute manière même s'il
y en a un des deux qui arrive au
deuxième tour ils franchiront pas la
barre du deuxième tour donc le gros du
problème sur cette élection c'est de
savoir si on va encore pendant cinq ans
un type qui nous a menti pendant cinq
ans je cite monsieur maquereau en
personne on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mercier à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cet échange philippe pascot
écrivant ex conseiller municipal de
manuel valls à evry et gilles la
casanova spécialiste en communication
et dans la ruche pour se faire entendre
au moment où cette campagne
présidentielle abat son plan les gilet
jaune au coeur de leurs préoccupations
toujours le pouvoir d'achat ils se sont
mobilisés une nouvelle fois ce samedi le
compte rendu d'un tgv razak les gilet
jaune sont arrivés à bon port place de
la nation s'est terminée cette
manifestation aujourd'hui qui a débuté
place cambronne manifestation qui s'est
déroulée dans le calme et la bonne
humeur avec des revendications qui ont
une nouvelle fois était répétée par les
gilet jaune parmi elles figurent une
hausse du pouvoir d'achat et des bas
salaires la mise en place du riq du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne ou
encore la protestation contre le pass
vaccinale a jugé liberticide par les
manifestants je vous propose d'ailleurs
à ce sujet est d'écouter certains
d'entre eux on est évidemment contre le
pass and i ter l'augmentation de
l'essence partout ce qui avait fait
sortir les gilets jaunes dans la rue
mais surtout
on a un président qui nous détestent
donc on veut surtout pas qu'il soit
réélu même si c'est hélas
ce qu'on craint plus il l'a dit lui même
il est là pour nous emmerder nous on est
là pour noircir son image une fois qu'on
a payé les charges y reste rien et à
partir de 10 du moins on n'a rien mettre
dans le frigidaire et en plus ce sont là
des enfances encore plus dur donc c'est
un monde qui est capitaliste qu à rêver
à la fin de course il faut créer un
nouveau monde un mot plus humanitaire et
plus sociale toutes ces âmes
ces espèces de choses acquises ont mis
en place dernièrement qui me font penser
un petit peu à ce qui se passe en chine
et à ça fait peur quoi et mais voilà
c'est tout simplement ça et c'est super
important
mais important que tout ne soit
conscient de ça mais je n'ai pas
l'impression et au milieu de ce parcours
de 8 km les gilet jaune se sont arrêtées
tout près de l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière pour apporter leur soutien à
neiger ben farhat un déclarant
historique et qui a eu un grave accident
de la route il ya une dizaine de jours
ils ont voulu lui apporter un maximum de
soutien un défilé jeunes qui sans
surprise en d'ores et déjà prévu de
continuer à manifester se faire entendre
pour peut-être pouvoir peser sur la
campagne électorale
la direction les états unis avec cette
nouvelle affaire qui ravive les tensions
à minneapolis deux ans après la mort de
georges flac tué par un policier blanc
un jeune afro-américain et morts tombés
sous les balles de la police casse est
passée mercredi
retour sur les faits avec théo combat
tension certaines images peuvent choquer
9 secondes c'est le temps qu'il aura
fallu pour qu'une banale opération
policière se transforme en une affaire
qui pourrait de nouveau agité des états
unis deux ans après la mort de john
floyd sous le genou du policier derek
chauvine c'est amerloques 22 ans sans
casier judiciaire qui a perdu la vie ce
mercredi détenteur d'un permis de port
d'armes le jeune homme se saisit de son
pistolet lors de l' irruption à son
domicile des forces de l'ordre au petit
matin une action qui provoque le tir
d'un des agents présents sur place une
exécution pour la mère de la victime
mon fils va être le visage et la voix de
ceux qui ne peuvent pas parler mais nous
allons nous assurer que nous parlons
fort pour amir il obtiendra justice tu
as thèse au coeur de la controverse le
mandat de perquisition pour une affaire
d'homicide dans une ville voisine et qui
ne mentionnait pas le nom d'amy rloc en
mandats dit noc c'est à dire sans
frapper à la porte et qui a pour but de
surprendre les perquisitionné problème
ce type de mandat est impliqué dans
plusieurs affaires de violences
policières baj
ils font interruption avant même de
s'être identifiés et ne laisse pas le
temps à amir de sauver sa propre vie et
c'est quelque chose que nous ne voyons
pas arriver aux citoyens blancs et le
fait que cela se produise à nouveau à
minneapolis est plus tragique c'est
odieux et
hajek et son compte le maire de
minneapolis a d'ores et déjà annoncé la
suspension immédiate de ce type de
mandat dans la ville et promet un examen
approfondi des pratiques de la police
des mesures qui pourraient bien être
insuffisante à endiguer l'indignation en
mécontentement d'autres jeunes pourrait
pâtir lui qui n'est pas parvenu à faire
passer sa réforme de la police pourtant
très attendue par les minorités
téhéran jugé insuffisantes les dernières
mesures américaines réactions au
lendemain de l'annoncé par washington de
la levée de restrictions liées au
programme nucléaire civil de l'iran les
états unis ont en effet décidé de
rétablir des dérogations clé qui
protégeait de la menace des sanctions
américaines des pays chez société
étrangers impliqués dans des projets
nucléaires civils en armes en iran elle
avait été annulée sous la présidence
trump les négociations sur le nucléaire
iranien sont en cours depuis le
printemps dernier coordonnée par l'union
européenne entre iraniens et grandes
puissances allemagne chine france
royaume uni et russie avec la
participation en direct les américains
et je propose écouté la ministre des
affaires étrangères
les américains doivent limiter leur
bonne volonté en action à notre avis
cela signifie des choses tangibles qui
se passe sur le terrain la levée d'une
partie des sanctions de manière réelle
et objective pourrait être interprétée
comme la bonne volonté dont par les
américains
ce qui se passe sur le papier mais ce
n'est pas suffisant les émirats arabes
unis partenaire privilégié de la france
en accord de coopération de défense
solide les deux parties c'est dans ce
cadre que paris va aider abou dhabi a
sécurisé son espace aérien contre les
attaques des rebelles yéménites outils
la france va ainsi envoyer des avions de
combat rafale français discobitch
sur la ligne de front les forces
gouvernementales continue d'accentuer
leur pression sur les rebelles houthi ce
vendredi elles annoncent avoir assiégé
la ville d'arad dans le gouvernorat de
hajjah dans une opération lancée
aujourd'hui les troupes de l'armée
yéménite soutenue par les forces
aériennes de la coalition ont réussi à
prendre le contrôle de larges zones de
arad au nord-ouest de hajar infligeant
des pertes humaines et matérielles au
rang de la milice outils soutenu par
l'iran les batailles se poursuivre arad
une ville particulièrement stratégique
sous contrôle des outils elle est située
à quelques kilomètres de la frontière
avec l'arabie saoudite
un des points de passages les plus
importants du yémen cette offensive des
forces gouvernementales a été menée par
une milice formés et entraînés par les
émirats arabes unis la brigade des
géants membres de la coalition militaire
dirigée par les saoudiens les émirats et
militairement le gouvernement du yémen
anga contre les outils depuis 2015 cette
guerre semble avoir franchi une nouvelle
étape ces dernières semaines trois
attaques revendiquées par les rebelles
yéménites on visait directement le pays
aux sept émirats ces attaques ont été
suivis par des représailles prenant la
forme de bombardements meurtriers de la
coalition notamment sur la capitale
sanaa face à cette montée des tensions
la france annonce ce vendredi apporté
son aide aux émirats les émirats arabes
unis ont été victimes de graves attaques
sur leur territoire au mois de janvier
afin de marquer notre solidarité à
l'égard de ce pays ami la france a
décidé d'apporter un soutien militaire
notamment pour protéger leurs espaces
aériens contre toute intrusion des
avions de combat rafale qui
appartiennent à notre dispositif
permanent basé à abou dhabi sont ainsi
engagés aux côtés des forces armées
émiriennes dans des missions de
surveillance de détection et
d'interception en cas de besoin
un soutien lié un accord de coopération
de défense signés entre les deux pays en
1995 et permettant à abou dhabi de faire
appel au soutien militaire français il
faut dire que les émirats sont le
cinquième client le plus important de
l'industrie d'armement française avec 4
milliards 700 millions d'euros de prises
de commandes entre 2011 et 2020 ce coup
de pouce de paris intervient quelques
heures après l'annoncé par les
etats-unis de renforts militaires sur le
sol émirati et du déploiement de leurs
destroyer lance missiles us s colle une
démonstration de force loin d'effrayer
la rébellion houthiste ces nouvelles
forces américaines qui sont arrivés ou
arriveront aux émirats ne nous font pas
peur nous n'arrêterons pas ce que nous
avons commencé nous défendre
c'est un droit légitime et nous ne nous
arrêterons pas tant que l'agression
contre notre pays ne cessera pas tant
que les forces soutenues par les émirats
arabes unis ne se seront pas retirés des
gouvernorats occupée
mis en cause pour de multiples bavure la
coalition militaire a reconnu des
erreurs mais accuse les outils
d'utiliser les civils comme boucliers
humains selon l'onu en plus de ces temps
la guerre au yémen a fait 3 177 mille
morts et placer les 30 millions
d'habitants du pays au bord de la
famille
et c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve à l'intérieur pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
aux uniformes